what do you think about uh the digital
world uh the metaverse
virtual reality will that have a
component in this or will most of our
advancement be in physical reality well
that's a little bit like Second Life
although the second life actually didn't
work very well because it couldn't
actually handle too many people and
I don't think the metaverse has
come to being I think there will be
something like that it will necessarily
be
from that one company I mean that's
going to be competitors but yes we're
going to live increasingly online
and particularly when if our brains are
online I mean how could we not be online
do you think it's possible that given
this merger with AI most of our
meaningful
interactions will be in this
virtual world
most of our life we fall in love we make
friends we come up with ideas we do
collaborations we have fun action about
somebody who's marrying somebody that
they never met yeah uh I think they just
met her briefly before the wedding but
she actually she actually fell in love
with this other person
uh never having met them
uh and I think it's I think the love is
real so that's a beautiful story but do
you think that story is one that might
be experienced as opposed to by hundreds
of thousands of people but instead by
hundreds of millions of people
I mean it really gives you appreciation
for these virtual ways of communicating
uh and if anybody can do it then it's
really not such a freak story
uh so I think more and more people will
do that
but that's turning our back on our
entire history of evolution well the old
days we used to Fall in Love by holding
hands and
and sitting by the fire that kind of
stuff here here I actually have five
patents on where you can hold hands even
if you're separated okay
um so the touch the sense it's all just
senses
it's not just that you're touching
someone or not there's a whole way of
doing it and it's very subtle and
But ultimately we can emulate all of
that
are you excited by that future
do you worry about that future
I have certain worries about the future
but not not that virtual touch
[Laughter]